boredom the desire for desires
anything is better than lies and deceit
each person's task in life is to become
a better person
truth like gold is to be obtained not by
its growth but by washing away from it
all that is not gold
it is amazing how complete is the
delusion that beauty is goodness
we are asleep until we fall in love
everything comes in time to him who
knows how to
[Music]
wait the changes in our life must come
from the impossibility to live otherwise
than the demands of our conscience
not from our mental resolution to try a
new form of life
let us forgive each other only then will
we live in peace
everything depends on upbringing
[Music]
man cannot possess anything as long as
he fears death
but to him who does not fear it belongs
everything
[Music]
you can love a person dear to you with
human love but an enemy can only be
loved with divine love
[Music]
only people who are capable of loving
strongly can suffer great sorrow
but this same necessity of loving serves
to counteract their grief
and heals them
a wrong belief does not cease to be
wrong because the majority share it
[Music]
if everyone fought for their own
convictions there would be no war
i often think that men don't understand
what is noble and what is ignorant
though they always talk about it
[Music]
god is the same everywhere
[Music]
the two most powerful warriors are
patience and time
if you look for perfection you'll never
be content
i simply want to live to cause no evil
to anyone but myself
[Music]
if you're not enjoying your work you
should either change your attitude or
change your work
[Music]
a truly wise man is always joyful
[Music]
the only thing that we know is that we
know nothing
and that is the highest flight of human
wisdom
it is much better to do good in a way
that no one knows anything about it
even in the valley of the shadow of
death two and two do not make six
[Music]
rummaging in our souls we often dig up
something that ought to have lain there
unnoticed
[Music]
spring is the time for plans and
projects
we lost because we told ourselves we
lost
if you want to be happy
be
all the variety all the charm all the
beauty of life is made up of light and
shadow
there is no greatness where there is no
simplicity goodness and truth
there are no conditions to which a
person cannot grow accustomed especially
if he sees that everyone around him
lives in the same way
[Music]
if we admit that human life can be ruled
by reason
then all possibility of life is
destroyed
[Music]
if there were no suffering
man would not know his limits would not
know himself
love the reason i dislike the word is
that it means too much for me
far more than you can understand
[Music]
when you love someone you love the
person as they are not as you'd like
them to be
it's hard to love a woman and do
anything else
historians are like deaf people who go
on answering questions that no one has
asked them
[Music]
everything that i understand i
understand only because i love
respect was invented to cover the empty
place where love should be
music is the shorthand of emotion
[Music]
rest nature books music
love for one's neighbor
such as my idea of happiness
[Music]
happiness does not depend on outward
things but on the way we see them
[Music]
i wanted feeling to guide us in life and
not life to be the guide to feeling
[Music]
all happy families resemble one another
each unhappy family is unhappy in its
own way
[Music]
true life is lived when tiny changes
occur
our body is a machine for living
it is organized for that that is its
nature
let life go on in it unhindered and let
it defend itself
have a goal in life a goal with a
certain time for a year a month a week a
day or an hour
and for a minute sacrificing lower goals
to higher ones
the chief difference between words and
deeds is that words are always intended
for men for their approbation
but deeds can be done only for god
[Music]
seize the moments of happiness
love and be loved this is the only
reality in the world
all else is folly
there is only one enduring happiness in
life to live for others
[Music]
kings are the slaves of history
one of the first conditions of happiness
is that the link between man and nature
shall not be broken
if a man aspires to a righteous life his
first act of abstinence is from injury
to animals
human science fragments everything in
order to understand it kills everything
in order to examine it
it's all god's will you can die in your
sleep
or god can spare you in battle
[Music]
nothing is so necessary for a young man
as the company of intelligent women
[Music]
everyone thinks of changing the world
but no one thinks of changing himself
every heart has its own skeletons
[Music]